what do you think is the meaning of life
i think that well
there are probably a couple of different
ways that
that i would go at this but i think it
gets back to this last question that we
talked about about the duality between
you have
the people around you who you care the
most about
and then
there's like this bigger thing that
maybe you're building um
and i think that in my own life i mean i
sort of think about this tension but
it's look i mean i started this whole
company and my life's work is around
human connection so
um
i think it's intellectually
probably
the thing that i go to first is just
that
human connection is the meaning
and i mean i think that it's a thing
that our
society probably
systematically under values i mean i
just remember you know when i was
growing up and in
in school
it's like do your homework and then go
play with your friends after and it's
like no well what if what if playing
with your friends is the point
like that sounds like an argument your
daughter should make well i mean i don't
know i just i just think it doesn't even
matter man
well i think it's interesting because
it's you know people
i think people tend to think about that
stuff as wasting time
or that's like what you do in the free
time that you have but like what if
that's actually the point yeah so that's
one
but but here's here's maybe a different
way of counting out this which is um
maybe more like religious in nature i
mean i always like
there's a
rabbi who i've studied with who who kind
of gave me this
we were talking through genesis and the
the bible and the torah and um
[Music]
and they're basically walking through
it's like
okay you go through the the seven days
of of creation and
um
and
it's basically it's like why does the
bible start there
right it's like it could have started
anywhere right in terms of like how to
live
um but
basically it starts with talking about
how god created people
in
his her image
the bible starts by talking about how
god created everything
so
i actually think that there's like
a
a compelling argument that i think i've
always just found meaningful and
inspiring that
a lot of the point
of what sort of religion
has been telling us that we should do
is to create
and build things
so these things are not necessarily at
odds i mean i think like
i mean that's
and i think probably to some degree
you'd expect me to say something like
this because i've dedicated my life to
creating things that help people connect
so i mean that's sort of the fusion of
of um
i'm getting back to what we talked about
earlier it's i mean what i studied in
school is psychology and computer
science right so it's i mean these are
these are like the two themes that
that i care about um
but i don't know for me that's what
that's kind of what i think about that's
what matters to create
and to uh
to love which is the ultimate form of
connection
i think this is one hell of an amazing
replay experience in the metaverse so
whoever is using our avatars
years from now i hope you had fun and
thank you for talking today
thank you
you